abone ol
e
[Alkış]
herkese merhaba şimdi o zaman gerçek
burada
bir oyunumuz olarak bahsetti Ama bende
Sizler kendi hikayeden bahsedeyim size
de amca anlattıklarım gibi olacak Ben
sana söyleyeyim ben
25 sene Basketbol oynadım ve Türkiye'de
değil kafasını Türkiye'ye getiren
25 yıllık bir basketbol geçmişi var
burada hakikaten ayarlarını
gerçekleşti
uyguladım ve
bu süreyi
Burada
çok fazla kaçacağım işte için sosyal
hayatı olmayan sokağa çıkmaya bilgisayar
rahatsızlık var
dünyadaki bütün İbo'yu fazlasıyla Uyar
uzamaya başladı Aslı doğduğunu da çok
büyük bir çocuktum yani 5,65
hazırlamış olarak Dünyaya getirdi
çok sevdim
Ben de
O hocanın izine biraz çek olacak ama ben
dışarıdan zorlamayla bozuldu Şöyle ki
annem çok istiyorum
istiyorum
Yani bu
Bu
otobüs
37 uzun boylusu Ne yapıyorsun Spor
basketbol oynuyorum bana söylediği şey
şu yok dedim ki yeni takım en kötüsü
olman lazım
bugün anca
salondan geceliğine ve dövme ile geçti
21 yaşında
şarkı
gençler ya
Sen beni 21 yaşında Basketbol Takımı'nın
kaptanı yaptı bu arada ben kez geldiniz
bugün
oyuncuları oldu
üst üste şampiyon olduk ya
[Müzik]
o bana verir
oyuncuları almak isteyenler Biz görmek
istiyorum o geldi mi
[Müzik]
en
iyi o bileti var balığın yanında bir şey
güzelleri var iyi şekilde oynamak uyum
içerisinde yer almak olduğunu
burada İlk o
[Müzik]
var
yani
Neredesin hiçbir zaman yaparak
maçlar başladı Avrupa Ligi vardı
yani pazartesi günü yola çıkıyordu
Arkadaşlar
bu da
[Müzik]
İyi
onlar da kocaman bir yazı çıktı böyle
yazdı Bana inanıyor musun hiç
[Kahkaha]
bu şarkıda gelişme olarak
Buraya giderken
Turgay Biçer bu mentour
psikolog zamanda bizim takılan öyle
Danışman olarak yani
bir şey istedi ki
oyuncuları bir Kendimiz için karşıdaki
[Müzik]
sonra o
o kız Galatasaray'ı
Herkes bizi tutuyor yani
ülkenin takımı olmuş herkesi destekledi
yani
yıkıldı
12540 h
[Müzik]
o orada Ee biz onları mahcup etmemek
için canla başla çalıştı ulaşması geldi
yani biz gelirken yere
[Müzik]
bayramda da siz daha sonra
size yıllar sonra sizi
bebeğimiz diye söylemişti yani Bu da
bizim hayallerimizi gerçekleştireceğiz
neler yaptığımızı çok fazla şey ortaya
koyar Şöyle ki
yani burada
biz bu hayallerinizi ortaya koyduğumuzda
çok iyi sırada Aslında ilham oldu
baktığımızda Fenerbahçe basketbol takımı
mı
Ne yani biz bugün aldığımız konuşmasını
98 96 sayısını aldığımız [ __ ] suyla
takıma ilham kaynağı oldu
onlarında bu işe yatırım yapmasına
vesile o
[Müzik]
oyuncu
Fenerbahçe basketbol
oyuncu olmaz çok beğendiğim bir oyuncu
baktığımız zaman
Ceylan o
bu yatırım yapmaya başladı işte Alperen
şeyi bugün Emre'yle yıldız olarak oyunu
geçince olarak oynuyor eşsiz bir hayali
vardır Giresun'da bal geldi basketbol
baktığınız zaman
o yüzden
hiçbir şey
bulamadım
yani
bir şekilde o
Ne oldu herhalde orada kimsenin giremedi
Vali size kupa daha önce fesleğen geldi
daha sonra Geçtiğimiz sezon
kapıyı kazandırdı bize Türkiye'ye getir
yani ayarlar herkesin işi şekilde ne
kadar siz gözünde olsanız da olmasanız
da bir şekilde bu hayalleriniz insanlara
bir şekilde dokunuyorsun
geçerli
ortaya çıkıyor o yüzden size anlatmak
istedim
Şöyle ki
herşey Hayal etmekle başlıyor O yüzden
hiçbir zaman bırakmak gerekiyor ve
okusaydım size uyumak olarak çıkacak
tekrar karşınızdayız
gerçekleştirdik ve
bu kelimesi hala Hayallerim sürüyor
basketbol bunu bir şeyler yapmaya
çalışıyorum Bir tane üzerinde durduğu ve
Araştırma yaptığımı oyuncu var Onlara
yetiştirip Emre'ye göndermek ve
Basketboldan
kazandırmak
hiç bir zaman
bırakma Çok teşekkür ederim O
[Alkış]